alors quand j'ai vu cette proposition de
thématiques
j'ai reconnu une part de moi zhu capte
blind side
regardons toujours vers la lumière vers
le côté brillant a été un moteur qui m'a
fait avancer
souvent beaucoup plus apprécié voilà
donc que je vais vous raconter la vie et
je vais vous lire ma vie en fait
exactement et je vais m'arrêter sur
quelques moments où j'ai dû lui faire et
prendre des décisions qui m'amène
aujourd'hui en fait à être le directeur
de l'école supérieure des arts visuels
de marrakech qui est une école de cinéma
mais aussi de graphisme école de
communication visuelle
voilà est-ce que j'ai vraiment toujours
regarder le bon côté des choses
qu'est ce qui a motivé mes prises de
décision est-ce que j'ai été seul où est
ce que l' influence de mon entourage a
joué un rôle
lequel est ce que l'héritage familial à
un rôle aussi est ce que j'écoutais
modèle qui m'ont inspiré qui me guide
hb il répond à ces questions je suis né
à casablanca où j'ai grandi jusqu'à 18
ans je suis le fils attendu le garçon né
dans une famille sicilienne où l'enfant
mâle a une grande importance que mon
attirance vers la lumière vient sans
doute de mes premières années au cours
desquelles j'ai été fêté comme un
miracle l'enfant désiré l'enfant a tenu
je peux dire que je suis né sous une
bonne étoile et que de bonnes fées se
sont penchées sur mon berceau est ce que
ces conditions favorables - était sans
aucun doute je peux l'affirmer
aujourd'hui pourtant sur pas mal
d'aspects cela m'a aussi handicapé et
j'ai dû faire un travail sur moi même
pour dépasser mes difficultés à
reprendre et le réel assumer les
problèmes dont ils se présentent au lieu
de les contourner a supporté la lourdeur
de la réalité après pâques j'ai quitté
le maroc
j'ai fait des études de théâtre de
cinéma littérature à paris à
l'université j'ai fait quelques
tentatives en tant qu'acteur je me suis
sega l'écriture mais je n'ai je n'avais
pas l'endurance ni le talent ni les
coûts suffisamment développé pour
persévérer dans cette voie
j'ai vécu ses années d'étudiant en
livrant ma liberté nouvellement acquises
hors de la famille j'étais pauvre je
vivais dans une chambre de bonne mais je
jouissais éperdument du charme de ma
jeunesse de mon pouvoir de séduction jeu
flirtait beaucoup
je papillonnait je faisais des promesses
que je ne tenais pas et je compterai
beaucoup de plaisir les plaisirs de la
vie parisienne en ne regardant que le
bon côté des choses
à la fin des années 70 dans
l'insouciance des trente glorieuses et
du plein emploi je partage avec mes
camarades étudiants comédiens des rêves
de gloire et de monde meilleur au début
des années 80 avec deux amis genre exit
permet un nouveau gîte aknin nous avons
repris la gérance de l'escurial une
vieille salle de cinéma à paris
cette expérience de gestion collective
m'a tout appris hier m'a appris surtout
à travailler avec l'énergie de nos 20
ans on stratégie à long terme des plans
d'action établi avec la force de mon
innocence de notre innocence notre envie
de cinéma est confiant de désir que nous
prenons pour la réalité nous avons fait
revivre cette salle nous n'avions pas
l'habitude de marcher notre culture
notre instinct de cinéphiles à la
recherche du violon classique que tout
le monde aurait envie d'aller voir
à cette époque il n'y avait pas de
vidéocassettes pas de dvd
nous avions moins de 25 ans et pas grand
chose à perdre à cette époque de nos
vies nous étions positif
nous regardions le verre à moitié plein
et nous avions raison pasco 15
conseillers sérieux nous aurait
encouragé à reprendre cette salle qui a
pourtant été un tremplin à tous les
trois la période de la gérante saturé 18
mois le propriétaire de la salle qui
avait gardé le patron aux surveiller cd
pris d'affection pour ce trio de jeunes
loups sympathique
est il acceptable de la montre pour la
racheter et faire des travaux il fallait
de l'argent
nous avons fait un emprunt à un taux
très élevé pour lequel nous avons
demandé à nos parents disputes étaient
des diamants avec cet emprunt et en
devenant gérant de la société j'ai cru
le premier engagement de malik également
le premier véritable le s'agit c'est pas
d'argent sonnant et comme champ il
s'agissait les d'hypothèque sur les
appartements et parents de jean jacques
et lien mais ce premier investissement
ne m'a fait sentir que même le poids le
risque est ce que malgré la conscience
de ce risque
j'aime mieux mesurer plus justement le
réel pas vraiment je ne savais
absolument pas gérer une entreprise
la preuve les travaux ont coûté 4 fois
plus plus de quatre fois plus cher que
ce qu'on avait évalué c'est cette
nouvelle aventure a commencé couvert de
dettes que nous étions incapables même
d'évaluer avec l'aide d'une subvention
d'un nouveau créé tille et surtout la
patience des fournisseurs que je
remercie au passage j'ai commencé à
comprendre ce qui était la réalité de la
trésorerie c'était l'intérêt d'anticiper
voilà deux semaines quand même arrivé à
pied dans les travaux et à rouvrir la
salle ma nature radieuse et mon
insouciance mon insoutenable légèreté de
l'être comme aimait dire jean jacques en
citant coderre a commencé à s'assombrit
de cette joie trio professionnels non
totalement liée là à nous à l'autre
parlant d'une seule voix nous avons
traversé quelques prises au relationnel
ce qui nous a sauvés et d'avoir respecté
cette consigne que nous avait donné
frédéric mitterrand alors collègues
exploitants
nos couches et jamais ensemble nous ne
couchera nos cochons ensemble mais nous
passerons la nuit à discuter à essayer
de trouver la bonne idée de
programmation a essayé de convaincre les
distributeurs de nous donner le chiffre
qu'on n'arrivait pas à voir et à la
suite d'erreurs
voilà j'ai pris conscience et j'ai fait
l'expérience penser la nes curial qu'il
avait une autre manière que celle de la
séduction fait du charme de la jeunesse
le jeune séducteur méditerranéen se
transforme
je me nourris de l'ombre je commence à
construire à kapitalis d'expérience et
je prends conscience qu'il ne suffit pas
seulement de croire à sa bonne étoile et
à son charme
en 85 quatre ans après la réouverture de
l'escurial mali personnel va changer
j'ai exactement 30 ans à l'escurial nous
avons rembourser nos dettes et nous
enchaînons les succès après sept ans de
vie commune avec christophe je tombe
amoureux d'un autre garçon yvan quitté
christophe pour vivre année qui vend
même si c'était ma décision a été très
court e et macabre pied je décide de
commencer une analyse de faire aider
est-ce que j'ai regardé vers la lumière
au moment de cette rupture amoureuse
oui parce que j'ai suivi ce que me
disait mon corps et mes senti
j'ai écouté mon désir et répondu à la
promesse cette nouvelle histoire
mais en lançant ce travail d' analyse je
décide dix ans après mon arrivée à paris
de m'inscrire encore plus dans le réel
talent et trouver la gravité en moins
sur le papier
est ce que le ciel parisien je vais
chercher en moi une autre lumière avec
jean jacques et brigitte nous vendons
l'escurial pour acheter rénover une
autre salle de cinéma le may cry d'err
sur les grands boulevards à paris
dès l'ouverture le maïs inverse est un
succès c'est la salle numéro un au box
office à paraître jean-jacques commence
à faire des films
brigitte développe des projets hors du
max mader et je gère presque seule la
salle c'est dans ces années là ne
commence à se construire des multiplexes
qui modifie le paysage de l'exploitation
cinématographique à paris le maxillaire
en tant que salle unique et indépendante
souffre de cette nouvelle concurrence
d'année en année les entrées baisse nous
décidons de mettre à la salle en vente
mais personne ne veut acheter une salle
en perte de vitesse on quotidien
commence à prendre goût amer comme mon
petit bureau sans fenêtre au fond du
hall mal payés travaillant 12 à 15
heures par jour avec la perspective de
faire faillite et de passer notre gré de
notre vie à rembourser les dettes
c'est dans ces moments-là que la devise
regardais toujours vers la lumière est
utile faut rester positif malgré les
difficultés
c'est ce que je fais je ne sombre pas je
tire la force et la lumière du travail
que je fais en a dix qui m'aident à
travers ses études
j'ai conscience que je chante pour que
je laisse derrière moi le jeune homme
lumineuse s'enivre des plaisirs de la
vie comme dirait serge daney un critique
de cinéma qui lui-même site jacques
lacan je sens que je passe de la
jouissance au plaisir voilà c'est cela
qui me rend disponible à faire de
nouvelles rencontres qui vont
bouleverser ma vie quand il m'arrive de
raconter d'histoires qui sont on me dit
tu as eu de la chance ou tu as su saisir
ta chance moi tout 94
je retrouve pour le week-end à nice à
une amie marocaine qui était au lycée
avec moi que je ne voyais plus beaucoup
elle est avec des amis dont un certain
bernard qui vit à marrakech et qui veut
pas d'une maison à louer dans la médina
l'idée de louer une maison à marrakech
vous plaît le projet m'excite je ne
doute pas alors que cette maison va
changer ma vie
vous allez voir vraiment c'est vrai
quelques mois plus tard en décembre
exactement je décide d'aller la visiter
j'entre pour la première fois dans la
maison je monte à l'étagé par l'escalier
situé dans le hall d'entrée est arrivé à
la hauteur d'une première terrasse qui
me permet de découvrir la cour
intérieure j'entends une voix non pas
une voix divine ou mystérieuses juste ma
propre voix qui me dit écoute cette
maison elle a quelque chose à te dire
c'est sûr qu'à ce moment là j'ai choisi
la lumière vingt ans après avoir quitté
le ciel marocain je le retrouve
je ne passe que quelques semaines par an
dans la maison mais elle mène à
traverser des mots les longs mois
d'hiver parisien elle est le point
brillant de malice
quelques mois plus tard nani le
directeur de la maison des cultures de
gould je me prends pour de rejoindre son
équipe et de devenir son secrétaire
général
j'accepte le pôle site tout en
continuant à gérer le match l'inter le
week end et à distance j'ai 40 ans j'ai
terminé le match analyse je vis seule je
n'ai pas envie de partager mallié pour
l'instant un pour l'instant et même si
ces deux années à bourges sont très
chargée en termes de travail
je sens que j'avance un jeu construit
incontestablement je sens que je cherche
une autre façon de regarder vers la
terre rouge allait faire appel
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses et
surtout moi qui n'avais jamais travaillé
en dehors de notre trio je découvre que
je sais faire plein de choses que j'ai
appris à diriger un lieu et jim
connaissance du public je sais et
l'elysée curiosité après plusieurs
tentatives échouées
enfin une proposition inattendue nous
est faite pour acheter max linder jean
jacques et moi entamant cette
négociation qui finit par aboutir au
moment où je suis pour quelques jours à
marrakech dans la maison je dois rentrer
d'urgence à paille les acheteurs sont
prêts à signer il faut aller très vite
je m'organise vont entrer en quelqu'un
sonne à la porte
change puisque l ancien directeur de
l'institut français de tanger veut nous
parler du poste de l'institut français
de marrakech qui veulent se libérer et
pour lesquels il n'y a pas de
remplaçants je décide d'être candidat ou
veufs l'avant du magasin d'air et
l'avancé de bons recrutements se font
pas aller loin et même si je n'ai aucune
certitude que l'un ou l'autre aboutisse
je décide de donner ma démission à
bourges
qu'est ce qui me motive à prendre cette
décision
est-ce que je parie sur la ville comme
un jour au casino non je ne crois pas je
le dis qu'il faut forcer le destin
je pense à ma maison je regarde vers le
côté brillant ma vie et j'ai confiance
et j'ai raison d'avoir confiance
nous vendons de max lambert et je suis
nommé à marrakech
comment expliquer cet enchaînement de
propositions plus à hazard de la chance
aujourd'hui avec le recul je pense qu'il
ya une part de chance je me suis trouvé
au bon endroit au bon moment
mais quelqu'un d'autre n'aurait pas
saisi cette chance l'expérience des
petits précédentes années ont permis de
construire de le construire et de
construire une relation aux autres arts
notamment une relation professionnelle
donne confiance mais sorte d'assurance
qui me fait retrouver le positif celui
acquis à la naissance dont je me sers
maintenant pour construire ce qui allait
m'apporter marrakech et ses potes de
direction et d'avoir à définir un projet
et d'en assumer seul la responsabilité
l'héritage mais le monde en france allez
pouvoir s'incarner dans un projet et
être au service d'une vision pour le
développement d'un établissement
omar hamadi je me sens bien là si tu es
français
je me sens à ma place j'ai la certitude
que je fais il a dix ans que je suis
utile je met en place des ateliers
d'écriture de scénario de danse
contemporaine de musique qui attire des
jeunes de lui tous différents et qui
révèle le manque de lieux de formation
artistique dans le pays j'ai été témoin
d'un engouement de leur part un désir de
s'exprimer par un médium artistique
d'agir sur la société de l'éveiller
veulent inciter à devenir actrice de son
propre destin
soyez cependant la limite de mon travail
je n'ai dit que de passage montre à ne
durer que quatre ans pour assurer la
pérennité et fallait créer une véritable
école d'art mais je n'avais pas les
moyens financiers de l'envisager c'est à
ce moment là que je rencontre susanna
qui venait de bâle
là il est arrivé à marrakech sont 98 la
même année que moi elle venait d'ouvrir
darbella un espace d'exposition coeur
historique de la ville entre la médersa
et la mosquée ben youssef
nous sommes devenus amis nous passons
des soirées à bavarder elle le pose
beaucoup de questions pour ce maroc sur
ce maroc à découvrir qu'elle aimait mais
qu il assure prôner zoug beaucoup
l'aspect nous découvrons ensemble les
mécanismes de cette société qui n'était
pas la mienne est donc
franchement être né et avoir grandi et
travaillé
nos discussions ont tourné beaucoup
autour de la jeunesse et de la
transmission
alors qu'approchait le terme de mon
contrat avec l'institut français
je lui ai appris que j'étais nommé à
londres et que je partirai bientôt de
marrakech elle était triste de
l'apprendre et manon sac avec max son
mari ils avaient discuté d'un projet
plus ambitieux que dar bellarj il avait
les moyens et voulait vraiment faire et
laisser quelque chose à ce pays
ils voulaient me proposait de créer avec
eux ce projet dans la sueur et la
direction
cette proposition me prend de court je
pars à leurs noms mais je ne reste que
deux ans je n'ai pas renouvelé mon
contrat j'ai mis fin à une carrière
toute tracée
qu'il me réservait un brillant avenir
ministère des affaires étrangères
français
est-ce que j'ai regardé la lumière ou
est ce que je lui ai tourné le dos
certes max et suzanne avait les moyens
de faire naître le projet mais est ce
que nous arrivions à le monter et
brouillon nous le faire vivre et
l'inscrire sur la durée j'ai fait le
choix de quitter la sécurité d'une
carrière tracé pour honorer cette
exceptionnelle proposition que me
faisait max et suzanne de créer cette
école que j'avais imaginé au maroc à
marrakech
j'ai choisi de mettre à l'épreuve à me
mettre à l'épreuve d'un nouveau défi
mais pas de la même manière
à l'époque de l'escurial comme un casse
croûte au sur un coup de tête des
audiences de la gym avait amené à
l'élaborer des principes sur lesquels je
veux m'appuyer pour construire le parc
ont minimisé
les obstacles faire face aux difficultés
appréhendés à leur juste valeur pour que
l'histoire avance et juin les jours en
septembre 2004 j'étais de retrouvailles
pour construire les sabres les comme les
étudiants à prendre et à regarder avant
de le faire mais aussi une école qui
conduirait à des métiers pour lesquels
pourrait gagner et construire leur vie
je suis certain que manager heureuse
mon attirance presque son année pour les
honneurs liés aux les textes de mon
enfance mon énormément servi
elles m'ont apporté de sourire à la vie
et des veillées par ce sourire
l'intérêt la curiosité des autres une
confiance a priori qui venait qui
devenait réciproque et qui m'a permis de
développer un réseau d'amitiés fidèle et
sincère ses amis pour la plupart des
femmes sont également des collaboratrice
brigitte anne jacqueline mari se
reconnaîtront mon grand ami hommes c'est
jean-jacques que l'on retrouve à
plusieurs endroits dans ce récit il a eu
beaucoup d'influencé sur - juifs
ashkénazes enfants déportés homosexuels
qui voue un amour passionnel à sa mère
il m'a apporté une part de sa conscience
douloureuse l'être au monde avec
l'humour et l'autodérision qui va avec
quand j'ai lu la proposition de
thématiques always look at the bright
side
j'ai souri en pensant à la phrase il
aimait souvent répété un peu de paranoïa
c'est pas cher
et ça peut toujours servir
est-ce que c'est son influence qui m'a
permis de mettre à distance mon
optimisme chronique c'est possible je
peux dire que j'ai toujours regardé vers
la lumière
né sous le soleil du maroc est percée de
mélodies italiennes j'ai été prédisposés
à regarder la vie positivement trop
positivement
il me manquait en entrant dans la vie
adulte à un peu du sens des réalités
un peu de poids pour regarde pour garder
les pieds sur terre mais années
parisiennes ont forgé mon caractère
elles m'ont apporté juste ce qu'il faut
de difficultés d'obstacles pour que mon
côté positif à bright side fin autre
chose qu'un atout de séduction qui le
servent à construire
aujourd'hui c'est avec et sur ses
expériences clair obscur que je trouve
ma légitimité à diriger une école
l'école d'art qui a pour mission
d'enseigner notamment le cinéma
le septième et dernier des arts qui se
sert de tous les autres et qui trouve sa
singularité à être l'un du divan qui se
produit devant nos yeux se vivent
dramatique qui se nourrit de la part
d'ombré des personnages et de la
résolution de leur conflit avec les
autres et avec eux mêmes
tous ces films qui nous aide aussi à
regarder régulière merci